hey guys welcome to reality check I'm
cam what's your favorite number I mean
they're all pretty great I like five and
pie and really any number that's over
nine you see that's a numbers can tell
us a lot about ourselves and also the
things that we love say video games so
this week and they came a special
episode of reality check we're gonna
explore some facts and stats and numbers
but you might not know about video games
[Music]
so I play video games you play games and
these guys are playing one right now
how many people around the entire globe
do you think actually play video games
millions tens of millions or maybe even
billions well according to a 2013 state
of the gaming industry report from the
folks at spill games there's an
estimated 1.2 billion people on this
planet who play games today sorry let's
just say that again 1.2 billion that's
17% of all the human beings alive today
it's equal to the entire population of
the world around the time Queen Victoria
was sitting on the British throne and if
the nation of gamers was a thing then we
would be the joint second biggest
country in the world tide of India and
second only to China and it's not that
far off the number of people use the
Internet globally today
[Music]
and speaking of the Internet of those
1.6 billion users what percentage of
them do you think spend some of their
online time gaming well about 44 percent
it turns out now that's a huge chunk of
Internet users and equates to over 700
million people in fact of all the
activities that people enjoy online
gaming comes in second in the popularity
race not far behind watching videos and
way ahead of TV films and radio combined
but back to that nation of gamers if
that country actually existed what would
the average member of that society
really be like who is the average gamer
today let's start with age now according
to the 2014 edition of essential facts
about the computer and video game
industry produced by the Entertainment
Software Association 31 years old is the
average age of game players perhaps more
surprising though are the numbers when
you split gamers up into age brackets
only 29% it turns out are under 18 32%
are between 18 and 35 and 39% are 36 and
older okay and what about gender how
close is the male/female split in the
gamer demographic well am I surprised
for me to learn that of all gamers 52%
or male and 48% are female
plus women aged 18 or older actually
represent a significantly greater
portion of the game-playing population
than boys under the age of 18
so we know how many of us gamers are
actually out there and we know what the
average gamer is like but what video
games are people actually playing well
gathering offline play stats is quite
tricky but if we look at online gaming
figures we can see that the most popular
type is casual on social games grabbing
30% of the share if we look at actual
sales figures over 2013 then its action
that comes out on top followed by
shooters and then sports games in third
place but what exactly is everyone
playing on you might wonder well over
half of all households in the US own at
least one console but that is not the
only way people play these days 36% of
gamers play games on their smartphones
with casual and social games being the
most popular on those devices
okay finally let's talk big money how
much is all of this industry actually
worth
well hardest 76 billion dollars and the
industry grew 9% in 2013 to reach that
gigantic figure which incidentally is
also equal to the net worth of Bill
Gates however according to research by
digi capital the value of the industry
is predicted to power on past that
figure and wind up being worth over 86
billion by 2016
that is hot on the heels of the global
movie industry - which is vided around
90 billion dollars however if you look
solely at the u.s. game sales versus
movie ticket sales in 2013 then we see a
very different picture with the games
hitting around 21 billion versus just
under 11 billion for box office sales
which ever way you look at it this
industry is huge in terms of value and
really only looks like it's gonna get
bigger so how many of the questions did
you get right was any of this new to you
and would you make of the size and value
of the games industry today let me know
in the comments down below
now next week on reality check there
won't be an episode why well because III
will be happening and I'll be there with
the rest of the games Bakhtin covering
the whole conference make sure you come
watch with us it all kicks off on Monday
at 9 a.m. Pacific time with a Microsoft
press conference and as for reality
check I'll be back in a couple of weeks
with a brand new episode so see you then
[Music]